>> This doesn't look like
the JSON we're used to.
Well, the truth is this data is JSON.
It's just JSON in it's raw byte form.
That's what all these hex numbers are.
In order to actually understand and
use it,
we'll need to convert it from raw JSON
into an object we can use in Swift.
And guess what?
Swift has just the class for us.
It's called NSJSONSerialization, and it
allows us to convert JSON into objects
like arrays or
dictionaries and vice versa.
Since we want to go from
JSON data to an object,
we'll use a method called
JSON object with data.
This take our raw JSON data and
returns either an NS dictionary or
an NS array,
which are both usable in Swift.
Okay, let's go use it in our code.
We can start back in this little spot
where we're printing the raw data.
Now, instead of printing it,
let's convert it.
We should start by using optional
binding to get our data out
of optional form and
make sure that it exists.
Then, let's create an object that
will eventually contain our parsed
dictionary result.
We can call it parsed result.
And now, let's add in that method
NSJSONSerialization.JSONObjectWithData
with data as our first parameter, and
AllowFragments as the second parameter.
And save that result
to our parsedResult.
What's this?
Can call throw, but it's not marked
with try and the error is not handled.
It looks like this method
can throw an error.
Let's use Swift's do catch block and
the try keyword to handle it.
If you haven't seen this error
handling syntax before, or
would like a refresher, feel free to
check out the Swift syntax course.
But overall,
this will be pretty straightforward.
Let's add the do catch block like so.
And then, put in the try keyword in
front of the potentially problematic
method call.
And that looks like that was it.
Should we try and print?
First, we should probably change
this data to parsedResult.
Let's try and print it.
Grab new image.
Cool.
This looks more like it.
For the record, serialization means
converting an object into a stream
of bytes, and deserialization
usually means the opposite,
converting a stream of
bytes into an object.
But for simplicity, Apple groups these
both under MSJSON serialization.